Wow besides this place
oh yeah weapon that damn when did that
happen you know it's been here since
I've been here oh really
hi I'm Marian it's good to see I get a
bit nervous I'll check into hotel the
windows are smashed anyway how are you
I'm good thank you I'm happy to be here
bullet holes you know they might very
well be I'm not sure what they are
we're 250 years old two new 50 years old
what's wrong with the place I think it's
beautiful place but I think it really
just needs some upgrading and which part
piece will help me
certainly not the entrance with a
smashed windows well I think it could be
beautiful
yes been neglected for a while what
happened here that looks much better
Wow dear oh dear just ripped a lot bit
with hello he's fantastic what time is
your calling in she might be here I
can't I've love to meet her oh he's
bringing Virender up for rent door hi
how are you good how are you
very liberal nervous smashed glance what
happened there it's been there since
before I bought it we have the hotel for
ten years ten years and you didn't think
about replacing it first impressions
customer ball to the door it's it's the
original have you been drinking drink
but did you run a hotel before we bought
this ten years ago no never
no what would you tear apart with
children over there for 20 years those
were practice Wow okay
201 I'll see you shortly I'm gonna go
check in and unpack okay
place is filthy
Maryanne I need a rag napkin
housekeeping please let me get
housekeeping for you house keep cool
fire brigade oh are you the housekeeper
I'm not I'm looking for I'm Caitlin
please me
sure know where was lost time this place
was cleaned it's dust and [ __ ]
everywhere today is here every day so I
would assume nice cleaning I mean under
here look I'm not talking about a couple
of weeks of dust I'm talking years and
behind here as well
oh geez
how are you hi he goes yes I'm fine fine
right what do you do housekeeping
stop which house this house come over
look at the mess down there what's that
fat little son let's get the place clean
fabulous let's just have a little test
here look at that look at that chip a
program that you clean for Westlaw a
program no no where is my room - you're
wrong now what's that up there who sits
here is it a [ __ ] tea party for rats
or Stuart little in for dinner tonight
what is that what is it like pet corner
we drop my cats off for dinner here
jeez my who does this hey guys come on
let's sit around let's talk about you
cleaning habits I think I do know I keep
my butt's way bigger than yours so take
see now have some menus please oh sure
yeah absolutely
so what in the [ __ ] is going on I
actually said something about that but
you know you comfy
absolutely